increased regulatory and compliance
requirements mean that protecting
sensitive data is top of mind for many
organizations data catalogs integration
with cloud data loss prevention DLP make
it easy to quickly discover PII
information and catalog it accordingly
up next we'll dive into how data catalog
helps you manage your sensitive data
sets
[Music]
Dero catalog is a fully managed and
scalable data discovery and metadata
management service that empowers
organizations to quickly discover
understand and manage all their data in
Google Cloud I am Anita keeping Gucci
and today we'll be tackling how to
manage your data assets with automatic
PII scanning capabilities using the DLP
integration in data catalog knowing
what's in your data is the first step to
understanding how to govern it
traditionally finding tagging and
handling PII
is an extremely manual on time-consuming
process cloud DLP integration and data
catalog scans your data and
automatically discovers what's sensitive
about it the data is then tagged and the
metadata pushed into data catalog so you
can easily search and govern it
accordingly
not only will cloud DLP inform you if
there's any PII in your data sets but it
will tell you what kind of PII cloud ELP
has over 90 types of sensitive data
identifiers including Social Security
numbers passport numbers birth dates and
more cloud DLP integration is currently
available via API only but will soon be
available within the data catalog UI as
a result you can process large amounts
of data quickly and automatically
simplifying the process of governing
sensitive data thanks for watching and
please check out all our data catalog
videos or visit our website to learn
more
[Music]
you